Xin phụ nổ đảng Lòng Ngài sẽ mất lợi thề cảnh trang trong hơn 2 mấy tư tỷ đủ là Mỹ hàng xuất khẩu,
sẵn Mỹ, mình nhận đến từ mức thời hàng mà là phần trăm mặt tổng đủ đủ năng trăm bữa đặt.
Khủ chỉ vầy, nổ còn có thể bị Mỹ áp thêm thời phát mời phần trăm vì vẫn nhập dầu từng á.
Nếu như thế này, sử dã, gần tảm ất thần trăm giá chỉ xuất khẩu, sẵn Mỹ của nổ sẽ vẻ hưởng.
Z-mai, dơ phẩm, mó chất và chẳng sức là những mặt hàng chình của mùi cơ thi thải năng.
Theo báo gạo nốt bộ mà hàng thông tần Rồi Tơ sải thác được từ chính phủ nổ cùng bụng ngày 1 xo thăm.
Tăng nổng từ các lệnh thêm mời của thẻ khiến tăng trưởng gồn đề phê của nổ,
giám không phải bốn đe vấn trăm.
Tuy nhiên, gần hàng chùa ngần đầu ở vận dựng, mùen dựng báo tăng trưởng cả năm ở mức xóo phy năng phần trăm.
Huyện phía Mỹ chưa công bổ mức thẻ áp của hi cùng lên hàng hãa nổ,
bởi Washington muốn chờ thông biệt tự mắt xe vã.
Chúc hạn chóp đừng bản tại uống quên nâh mừng tạm thăm.
Đặc phía viên Mỹ Street with Cop đã có mặt tại Más Coba để thuộc đẩy trình này.
Anh đồ cũng đăng tăng cường lên hệ bình á bằng việc cửa của vấn án ninh cú ra,
á gít đồ văn đến Más Coba để bán vây dấu mỏ và các hợp đồng cú phòng.